drei leute herzlich willkommen zu diesem
video ich bin jetzt zusammen mit esi am
ort des geschehens ihr habt unsere
beiden videos gesehen wo wir unsere
autos umgebaut haben zu kampfmaschinen
hier sind wir jetzt auf einem
privatgelände oder der erste rennen sagt
habt das video gesehen wo wir unseren
umgebaut haben so kann's verstehen
könnte es auch keinen gast
wir sind ja auch als quasi länder und
treten hier gegeneinander an und jetzt
gucken wir uns erst mal gegenseitig
unsere augen lose hier darunter befindet
sich mein auto meine zuschauer canons
bereit hier drin befindet sich mein auto
meine fans bereits
aldersbach
pauli steht also die ein oder andere
idee dafür aber bei mir auch so eine box
ist alter diese schrauben waren auch
mein erster gedanke habe ich aber nicht
im video erzählt aber das ist mein
erster gedanke aber dann hab ich
irgendwie verworfen aber wo ist das wird
ganz es könnte echt spannend wäre ja
okay weil wir waren uns überhaupt nicht
sicher ob ein hessen kraftlos und
schlecht ist eine komplett andere taktik
ok wissen auch dass tiger oben drauf
hast du ja ich habe mir auch gedacht
sollte ich vielleicht dahinter sieht auf
jeden fall viel professioneller viel
prof
aber das ist nicht wichtig am ende dank
das jawort und instant rande skizzierte
der vermerk abonnieren
man kann ja vorwärts andere gesetzt
haben okay aber die sache ist bei mir
ich habe ordentlich gewicht drauf
gepackt
das wären wir gleich sehen heute
natürlich auch sein dass er sich
irgendwann dass ich auch er sehe ich
dachte ich gesagt jetzt nach einem
glatten boden gebundenen brenner anleger
der mitte ist es so ein panzer das ist
echt aus dieses wetter bot sich einfach
so ein stück blech legen weiß noch nicht
ob das jetzt drei
[Musik]
vergleicht ist aber so ein feuerzeug
scheiße als echten folter oder es nicht
rund sondern es ist doch eine zum
blockieren so aber den kann ich mir bei
der karriere schon mal endlich auch im
großen haben können das bringt muss auf
jeden fall verhindern dass so lange an
mir dran hängt 3
mein aufruf so lange habe ich bekomme
einfach als vorher
man mag es wenn man einen film machen
erklärt einfach nicht mehr was los
leider reifen ist das leben
der panzer dick eingepackt das ist
wirklich dicker junge und zu brenner
bunsenbrenner sichtlich froh als ich
krieg dich sehen war nicht angetreten
das zu uns mit der flachen seine flamme
alter die geht voll war auch absolut
bitte wissen damit also immer ein
bisschen weiter weg
genau wissen wir das jetzt die höchste
scheint den reifen komplett geschmolzen
damit verbunden oktober
geschickt wird
sie laufen behauptet zudem aufträge als
explodiert gleich bis jetzt so langsam
kann ich jetzt hier von winsen langsam
an wurde ich ein bisschen das muss ich
kann man langsamer sei natürlich ein
bisschen anders
der aufenthalt oder auf meinem lachen
parkettboden folge schließen jetzt bei
mir aus der hand
die separat einfach weiter dann kurz
angeguckt main hat nun keinen links rein
toscani sagte eigentlich in so klein
geworden sein soll
wir sind richtig andere werden aber von
der seite konnten die reifen ja doch an
erster oder zweiter riss gegrillt vor
der die reifen brennen wird geschrubbt
ca
die reifen sind diese reifen sind
komplett profil verloren
richtig tief eingebrannt werden wir da
stehen geblieben ein auto war verbrannt
jungen bisschen stehengeblieben
wer verwandte ich hätte nicht wegfahren
können perfekt machen
machen wir das schild nur den
bunsenbrenner dran manchmal gehörten
panzer ab dann habe ich ja nichts mehr
doch in den schuh so ist rennt ja hinten
sieht man ja auch gar nicht als
gemeingefährlich
[Gelächter]
das ist verging street alter
märz ab
ok wirklich ansehen
weil das selber nicht mehr gefragt
ok ok aber da fehlt doch und max reifen
dran und reif ist reif hat glaube ich
ein bisschen gebrannt leute betont
wo jetzt drei jungen reifen
zurück
sein eigener job deine reifen auf
frage wird immer wieder junge ja er kann
nicht mehr sein werden ich würde sagen
wir kommen zur bilanz weil es gibt
glaube ich wir hätten wenn wir ein
wirklich gewinnen ich muss sagen hat
übertrieben spaß gemacht umzubauen
wirklich mega heiß aber die autos waren
einfach zu sparen ja als das jetzt
irgendjemand als klare gewinnerin
ja der neuen volt akku da hat
funktioniert aber das hat sich irgendwie
auf signale wenn ihr das format hier
feiert und wenn ihr sagt dass wir da
bock drauf habt dann machen wir ein teil
2 mit stärkeren autos krass und
modifikation mehr budget das wir
beispielsweise irgendwelche messer oder
so wolf verbrannten können wir können
auf jeden fall den kommentaren abstimmen
wer der gewinner ist ich muss ganz klar
sagen erster eindruck hast du für mich
auch übers feld der gewinner sieht viel
viel geiler aus aber es ist kein rundes
konzept gewesen er war viel zu schwer
und konnte schon von anfang an nicht nur
sehr langsam anfang war der super
langsam und haben am ende kann ich mich
gar nicht mehr bewegt wird er sagen ihr
habt ihr mit wir haben ein paar
verbrannten reifen hier hier und da mal
so ein bisschen angeguckt deshalb wir
brauchen mehr power aber wir wollten
jetzt hat auch keine 400 euro
autos kaufen für die erste das erste mal
wenn es euch trotzdem gefallen hat
lassen das war sehr lustig mitleid für
enke in den chat wir sehen uns wieder
wieder